I don't know you know what's crazy
whoever is the first presidential
candidate that comes out and says
and just like imagine if Joe Biden
really wanted to win again yeah and if
Trump wanted to just grab all of the
left's votes they literally would come
out and just say we're going to make
marijuana federally legal and everyone
who's in prison for weed is getting
released that's what they need to do
everybody would vote for that person
normal people would be like
I mean well I mean I think you and I
were like from liberally leaning cities
yeah you go to the Midwest bro there's a
stark difference between the attitude I
feel like even the Rednecks I know love
weed yeah yeah they all [ __ ] smoke
weed and they all probably have cousins
that are in jail for weed offenses it's
like dude like
what the [ __ ] yeah well the weed should
the war on drugs is just crazy in
general they need to like prohibition
has never worked for anything
historically ever right all I know is
what I knew about the War on Drugs when
I was a kid was all because of a mortal
technique yep and it's true but it's
like you have this [ __ ] going on with
the War on Drugs right you have families
being separated because it's only
hitting certain communities right you
have a whole black market economy that's
been created to like perpetuate this war
right in this endless [ __ ] uh
enemy-less War
and all it does is like keep people in
prison
keep you know the money printers on for
like the police the prison industry yeah
and it's like
it doesn't stop drug use would you be a
proponent of legalizing drugs legalize
all of it bro because people are [ __ ]
we're just talking about it I walked
through downtown Los Angeles right now
and I'm breathing in crack smoke anyways
right so at least if you decriminalize
it you could regulate it so it could be
regulated there could be places where
people aren't getting [ __ ] fentanyl
laced [ __ ] pills exactly and there's
no black market economy people getting
shot
cartel would be a lot less powerful yeah
because I think Mexico is about to
legalize I think I saw they were no no
no Colombia is legalizing cocaine why
not so that's gonna [ __ ] up it's their
entire economy anyway so they're gonna
legalize it it's Columbia I saw that all
drugs
and it makes sense because think about
all the violence that's used to support
the drug trade no for sure I think as
much as it might
push people to try drugs more
I think that you'll save a lot of lives
in the long run yep and there's also
like
with drug use there's a stigma right
with addiction right and if you start to
decriminalize or legalize in some cases
drugs like it it helps like if
chemically treating addiction worked
you could get a nicotine patch and stop
smoking cigarettes right yeah but
there's so many other things that are
factored into what keep you [ __ ]
stuck on a substance right you have the
social component you have the emotional
component and it's like
if you decriminalize things and you
start to destigmatize them at least it
allows you to re-socialize if you're an
addict yeah and I think too it also
removes the romanticization of it for
like a kid growing up because I know in
some countries where like the drinking
age is like 14 like there's like less
alcoholics I think it's Italy yeah it's
like yo like if people want to try [ __ ]
because they think it's like oh [ __ ] I'm
rebelling I'm [ __ ] I'm uh I'm gonna I
can't try this [ __ ] I'm gonna go find it
but if it's like if it's just readily
available I think it'll make it like
less popular with kids which is kind of
weird to say no it makes perfect sense
because people want to do what they
can't do especially at that age like
human nature yep if you're a kid you're
trying to assert your Authority and
Independence right yeah so why wouldn't
you yeah it'd be no different than like
I mean look at the end of the day
alcohol is probably way more deadly than
a lot of drugs which is yeah maybe
except like fentanyls yeah opiates yeah
I would say but like it's probably more
deadly than a mess
maybe I don't know about enough about
meth neither do I but I but I mean I
would venture to say that would alcohol
probably have killed more people every
year than meth I don't know we should
look that up
unless you're smoking [ __ ] fentanyl
lace meth yeah which is where it's you
know but that's why you need to legalize
Mass so you could regulate what you
should be able to just go to the store
and buy some [ __ ] Adderall well
that's what happens with drugs right
like if you're buying heroin on the
street it's strong on Tuesday so you
need two bundles but then on [ __ ]
Thursday it's week so you need six
bundles but then Friday you go to use
again it was week yesterday but they hit
you with the strong dose they hit you
with that fetty and you're [ __ ] dead
yeah it's crazy yeah yeah I hope you I
mean I think like the thing about uh you
know pills and and heroin and all that I
mean that [ __ ] if it's if it was
regulated if you could go somewhere I
know you're getting a safe dosage and
you know I feel like like it still sucks
you should try to get off of it for sure
but at the same time like either way
you're gonna get the drugs just now you
remove the
sharing needles HIV [ __ ] [ __ ] people
overdosing fat no you kind of remove a
lot of the um power from the cartel yep
yeah there's like and you're not going
to stop people from [ __ ] using drugs
you're not gonna stop people from using
drugs